l'irak et l'iran prêts à négocier mais
bagdad n'exporte plus son pétrole
matt quarantaine de le monde devrait
soutenir un gouvernement iranien en exil
attentat antisémite à paris indignation
générale dernier volet de notre enquête
sur le cir générateurs aujourd'hui
l'exemple français
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir dans trois
heures réunion probable du conseil de
sécurité à l'onu à l'initiative dû
secrétaire général monsieur van ryb
je vous rappelle que désire ce par les
états unis et l'urss était convenu de
chercher par tous les moyens à apaiser
les choses sur le terrain
mais les combats continuent avec
violence l'aviation et règne à la
bombarde et les plus importantes
installations de pétrole de l'irak et
l'exportation du pétrole irakien a été
interrompu les oléoducs sont fermés or
la france importe 25% de son pétrole
d'irak
les envoyés spéciaux d'antenne 2 ont pu
parvenir jusqu à bassora qui est le plus
grand centre irakien de l'industrie du
pétrole
voici des informations que nous transmet
jaunards se bat toujours rage de part et
d'autre du channel arabe entre irakiens
iraniens dans la ville de bassorah
objectif de l'aviation iranienne des
réservoirs de pétrole de la racine vie
dégageant une énorme colonne de volume
et dans les rues les musiciens
patrouille la kalachnikov à la main tout
et cannes et irène alerté yens les rares
passants se colle contre les murs
alors que vers le ciel non les balles
traçantes et des tirs de décès à les
alerter aériennes vont cependant moins
nombreuses les irakiens ont maintenant
limité
plusieurs points du territoire iranien
ils ont déjà percé on tire au canon et à
la mitrailleuse lourde dans plusieurs
villages capturés par les irakiens à
quelques kilomètres de là sur les rives
du chott el arab le fleuve qui formaient
jusque là la frontière entre les deux
pays
l'armée irakienne attaque la raffinerie
d'abadan depuis deux jours l'un des plus
vastes complexes pétroliers du monde à
badens est en flammes
la raffinerie a cessé de fonctionner
tout comme les installations pétrolières
de l'irak et notamment kirkouk
d'où le pétrole ne s'écoule plus même
vers la méditerranée
pendant ce temps au centre des 1200 km
de frontière l'armée irakienne continue
de progresser lentement couverte par un
véritable barrage d'artillerie former
des fameuses katioucha les orgues de
staline qui peuvent tirer deux requêtes
à la seconde
la riposte de l'iran c'est l'aviation et
les bombardements réguliers de bagdad
que les irakiens ne peuvent empêcher
malgré leur défense aérienne mais
téhéran vite aussi en état d' alerte peu
de circulation dans les rues
extinction des feux dès la tombée de la
nuit la population obéi aux ordres école
du papier aux fenêtres pour empêcher que
les carreaux ne vole en éclats en cas de
bombardement
mais surtout les bureaux de recrutement
accueille des milliers de volontaires
qui offrent leur vie pour défendre le
pays car la république islamique est
aujourd'hui en danger
l'ayatollah khomeiny lui même appelle
ses fidèles a versé leur sang pour la
patrie et demande aux irakiens de se
soulever contre le régime en place à
bagdad
je vous rappelle que le but hier soir
plusieurs centaines de ressortissants
français qui résidaient en irak ont
commencé à regagner paris par des vols
spéciaux on ne signale d'ailleurs
heureusement aucune victime parmi les
français résidant en irak est d'ailleurs
la plupart des sociétés françaises ont
décidé de maintenir sur place leur
personnel et de rapatrier seulement les
personnes non indispensables là bas
sachez en tout cas que les ptt n'accepte
plus d'envoi par poste aérienne ni pour
les rangs me pria qu on attendait avec
impatience et un très vif intérêt la
réaction vannes iranien en exil en
france depuis deux ans mais qui
entretient depuis longtemps de bonnes
relations avec le régime irakien
cet homme c'est bien sûr monsieur
chapour bakhtiar qui sort de son silence
en exclusivité pour un tome 2 et qui
confie à bernard benyamin et paul nahon
des objectifs véritable du gouvernement
j'ai passé l'essentiel c'est de
déraciner robes et ensuite il y aura
moyen de s'entendre pour moi c'est très
net
la corde 1975 est toujours en vigueur et
il n'y a pas un mètre carré de l'iran a
cédé à quiconque que ce soit je bâtir
seriez-vous prêts aujourd'hui à former
un gouvernement iranien en exil qui
serait reconnu par les irakiens
si c'est seulement par les irakiens
n'ont pas requis alors ça soit même
il ya qu'il y ait un consensus
international lundi pas tous les pays
mais un grand nombre de pays
surtout du voisinage et les pays
d'europe si il cesse de flirter comme
ils ont fait pendant toute une année
avec monsieur khomeiny si votre
intention en tout cas j'ai l'intention
mais je le ferai pas en france le chien
vous étiez à bagdad récemment monsieur
bah tiens j'ai essayé déjà cinq fois à
bagdad depuis un an
mais dans les jours derniers nous leur
donnons je ne sais pas avec gc ailleurs
en effet ailleurs ça je peux le garder
comme secret vraiment je n'étais pas en
irak
le chargé d'affaires iranien affirmé
hier sur l'année lé mans que vous
disposiez d'une armée qui interviendrait
actuellement contre les iraniens aux
côtés des irakiens et côté je crois que
le jour où gérard neyrand il n'y aura
pas d'armé et régnier qui sont penserait
à moi parce que je n'ai rien fait contre
l'armée iranienne
et c'est précisément sur khomeiny qui
l'a les racines et démantelé a fait
toutes les bêtises qu'il a pu faire
pendant un an on voyait tous les jours
ils bousillent les gens absolument sans
mouvement se sont déneigés des généraux
et des techniciens mais vous avez des
militaires qui sont à vos côtés
je crois que les six avaient 6e étaient
libres en iran à 9 sur 10 serait de mon
côté non seulement tellement pour
sympathie pour moi c'est khomeiny qui
les tue qui les élimine que les en bas
des ordres d'une ville de l'iran s'il
peut ou les mains en prison alors par
conséquent j'ai de bonnes raisons de
croire que ces gens là n'ont pas tout de
même une très bonne opinion dans leur
commune i monsieur bastia vous avez
l'impression que l'heure de votre tour
louchant votre tour est proche j'ai
l'impression d'un fan de khomeiny chante
en fait tout le monde est d'accord la
guerre iran irak ne peut pas s'éterniser
et une partie diplomatique considérable
est engagée georges bortoli au plus haut
niveau international
oui on veut dire ce soir il ya tout de
même un élément nouveau c'est la prise
de position tout à fait officielle du
ministre des affaires étrangères irakien
plisson qui déclare que son pays est
prêt à des négociations et 200 go t
l'iran accepte officiellement également
le principe d'une mission de bonne
volonté du président de la conférence
islamique le général zia ul haq
le pakistanais zia au lac qui sera
demain à paris où hier était le vice
premier ministre
de l'irak autrement dit paris paraît
jouer un petit peu un rôle de pivot dans
la mort ce d'une négociation éventuelle
et léger après d'ailleurs une position
tout à fait clair par la bouche de son
porte parole adjoint javelot tout à
l'heure en encourageant en irak
justement à la négociation
autrement dit ne nous laissons pas
tomber dans un optimisme facile pour des
démonstrations de bonne volonté qui pour
l'instant sont verbales mais tout ce
passe comme si après la démonstration de
puissance pas très très réussie
d'ailleurs de l'irak
les deux belligérants chercher de
maintenant une porte de sortie qu'elle
porte le chantier une porte de sortie
internationale il faut bien se rendre
compte que depuis le début ces affaires
se joue à deux niveaux en bas il y à un
conflit frontalier tout à fait classique
le type même du conflit limité et
locales mais tout autour de cela comme
vous le disait il y a une énorme une
considérable activité diplomatique
internationale
washington et moscou ont en tout cas
sont tombés d'accord dès hier soir pour
rester neutre dans le conflit
oui mais disons que et washington et
moscou par est même suspecté un petit
peu la neutralité de l'autre et il est
exact de dire que le président carter
chouette réunir une conférence de ses
amis occidentaux pour faire quelque
chose pour la libre navigation dans le
détroit d'ormuz pour l'instant c'est une
invite modeste puisqu'il s'agit d'une
conférence éventuelles et au simple
niveau des experts
mais c'est assez pour que la pravda y
explique et écrivent que les américains
sont en train de se chauffer les mains
au feu de la guerre
donc il vaut mieux que tout ça se
termine et se terminent très vite
d'abord pour les gens qu'on bombarde à
mossoul à khoramshahr adhérents à bagdad
et aussi parce que malgré le sang froid
dont fente encore jusqu'à présent preuve
les deux super grand se confie chez
déroule quand même pour le monde entier
dans une région beaucoup trop chaude est
beaucoup trop dangereuse
une information que je reçois la
bulgarie et la roumanie ont décrété
l'arrêt total de leur exploitation de
leurs livraisons de pétrole
un raison pour du moins en direction de
leurs clients occidentaux et les deux
pays bas roumanie la bulgarie invoque le
cas de force majeure alors les rumeurs
d'une négociation entre baghdad des
terrains sont en tout cas parvenus
jusqu'à la bourse de new york où les
cours de l'or ont sérieusement baissé
l'once a perdu 40 dollar s'établissant à
670 dollars environ j'aurai mon bar en
visite officielle en autriche a dit au
cours d'une conférence de presse à
vienne
la coopération de la france avec l'irak
n'est pas seulement militaire elle
touche aussi l'industrie la technologie
la culture
les deux pays ont toujours eu des
relations confiantes nous n'avons de
leçons à recevoir de personne sur les
livraisons d'armes françaises et je
demande à ceux qui s'intéressent à la
question de considérer également les
ventes d'armes faites par d'autres
tel est le résumé de ce qu'a dit
monsieur bart maintenant des précisions
de vienne par piranha ce qui nous paraît
essentiel dans cette affaire c'est que
la liberté de circulation dans le
détroit d'ormuz puisse être sauvegardés
ceci est nécessaire non seulement à la
france mais bien entendu à l'ensemble
des pays européens qui s'approvisionnent
en pétrole auprès des pays du golfe vous
m'avez posé une question sur les ventes
d'armes de la france et l'irak
je profite de cette question pour
préciser deux points en premier lieu la
coopération de la france avec l'irak
n'est pas seulement une coopération
militaire
elle est une coopération qui se
développe dans tous les domaines
industriel culturel le domaine de la
technologie avancée nous avons 4500
français qui travaillent en irak
nous avons toujours eue avec ce pays des
relations politiques confiante lira
comme la france sont attachés à leur
indépendance et le problème
des ventes d'art n'est qu'un problème
tout à fait limité dans l'ensemble de
l'accord et de la coopération irako
française
ma deuxième observation est que je
voudrais une fois pour tout dire à ceux
qui s'intéressent aux ventes d'armes par
la france de bien vouloir considérer les
ventes d'armes qui sont faites par les
autres pays et je dis de la manière la
plus nette que nous n'entendons cherche
point recevoir de leçons de personne à
l'époque que les approvisionnements en
pétrole peuvent donc d'un jour à l'autre
se réduire à peu de choses voire à néant
les autres moyens de production
d'énergie devient essentiel le président
de la république a d'ailleurs rappelé
tout récemment que dans le monde comme
il va la politique nucléaire française à
querrey sa pleine justification
c'est donc avec un intérêt accru je
pense que vous continuerez à suivre
notre enquête sur les surrégénérateurs
une série d'émissions mené conjointement
par antenne de europe 1 et qui se
terminera lundi 29 sur un trentaine par
un question de temps exceptionnel avec
audition publique
ces jours derniers nous vous avons
montré plusieurs exemples sur l'année 2
l'avenir les surrégénérateurs l étranger
ce soir bernard rapp ou propose le
dossier france créé smallville à 65 km
au nord de lyon c'est ici que se
dressera superphénix le premier
surgénérateur commercial français
construit en coopération avec l'italie
l'allemagne et l'angleterre
superphénix sera avec 12 100 mégawatts
le plus gros surgénérateur commercial du
monde
l'outil énergétique le plus sophistiqué
jamais créée par l'homme pourtant il ya
un peu plus de trois ans se déroulait
ici
rappelez-vous la bataille de maleville
soixante mille manifestants venus de
toute l'europe se heurter à 15 cents
gendarmes et crs
bilan un mort le militant écologiste de
vital michalon et des dizaines de
blessés or aujourd'hui le chantier du
futur surgénérateur a considérablement
avancé
ils devraient être terminés en 1983 à
l'origine de la décision du gouvernement
et du constructeur en l'occurrence
électricité de france
une double considération d'abord la
technique est au point ensuite l'état
des ressources énergétiques de la france
à pouces ce choix vous avez là
l'aboutissement de 25 ans d'efforts qui
a commencé par rhapsody par phoenix qui
marchent maintenant depuis
six ans depuis 74 et qui marche comme
une montre et vous avez là un réacteur
qui va fonctionner en 1983 pourquoi
l'indépendance nationale et bien le le
combustible qui est consommé dans ses
réacteurs là se retrouve à la sortie
pour 1 kg de combustible brûlé dans ce
réacteur
vous trouvez à la sortie un kilo un
quart de combustible vous utilisez une
certaine cote et prohibe la sortie de
retrouver davantage
finalement le résultat pratique de tout
ceci c'est que l'uranium dont nous
disposons en france à peu près 100 mille
tonnes représente à travers ses
réacteurs rapide représente pour la
france pour l'avenir des réserves
d'énergie qui sont équivalentes à
l'ensemble des réserves de pétrole du
monde entier je crois que c'est ça
l'enjeu pour avoir une idée de la
dimension de superphénix quelques
chiffres sont éloquents
cent cinquante mille mètres cubes de
béton ont été coulés la cuve destiné à
recevoir les 5000 tonnes de sodium qui
refroidiront le coeur usure 23 mètres de
diamètre et pèse 260 tonnes enfin 12
millions d'heures de travail sont
nécessaires pour arriver au bout du
chantier
et ce gigantisme est précisément l'un
des reproches adressés par les opposants
de superphénix le réacteur de
démonstration du même type
phoenix qui fonctionne actuellement à
marcoule possède une puissance de 250
mégawatts superphénix sera cinq fois
plus saura-t-on alors maîtriser un
pareil outils
autre problème relevé par les opposants
celui du retraitement la mise en place
de surgénérateur suppose une importante
capacité de retraitement du combustible
nucléaire
or aujourd'hui l'usine-pilote de la
rague n'a pas rempli ses promesses
c'est un point qui restent à régler
avant de se lancer dans l'exploitation
commerciale des surgénérateurs enfin
dernier reproche fait ou surgénérateur
pour les opposants sa rentabilité et
puis pour deux raisons principales la
première c'est que ce ne serait rentable
qu aux alentours de 2040 2050 à peu près
et encore si tout va bien
actuellement le prix du kilowattheure du
surgénérateur ce serait le plus cher de
tous les kilowattheures produits par
toutes les sources d'énergie
et puis en 2040 2050
l'énergie solaire sera prête à prendre
la relève ceci évidemment je ne vous
parle et c'est si tout va bien si tout
va bien ça veut dire s'il usine de
retraitement de la hague fonctionne si
on peut manipuler sans trop en danger le
plutonium c'est le corps polluants un
des pluies 2 qui puisse exister c'est
excessivement dangereux
et puis si on peut maîtriser tous les
problèmes de sécurité posés par le sang
générateur ce qui n'est pas encore le
cas
par conséquent moi je dis très nettement
c'est maintenant que l'on choisit ou
bien le surgénérateur les dangers et le
prix le coût ou bien l'énergie solaire
qui elle est sans danger est inépuisable
et puis qui se prête à une société qui
est beaucoup plus est centralisé et puis
beaucoup plus à écrire des livres
à cet argument de coûts edf répond que
la production série des surgénérateurs
devrait faire considérablement baisser
le prix du kilowatt heure avant
d'ajouter que le surgénérateur n'exclut
pas les recherches et l'utilisation du
solaire
toujours est il que le choix que doit
faire aujourd'hui la france est capital
en effet si la filière du surgénérateur
est retenue elle engage le pays pour
près de 150 ans c'est pourquoi antenne 2
et europe 1 ont demandé à quatre députés
représentant les quatre grandes
formations politiques françaises de
venir en débattre en public lundi 29
septembre à 20h30 dans l'émission
question de temps donc rendez-vous à la
discorde vague d'attentats anti sémite à
paris l'année dernière
aux premières heures de la matinée en
quatre points différents de la capitale
un vitrail et des locaux qui ont tous le
judaïsme comme caractéristique commune
une crèche israélite une école juive une
synagogue et le mémorial du martyr juif
inconnu ces attentats sont signées des
croix gammées ont été dessinées sur les
bâtiments mitrailler et les actions ont
été revendiquées par les faisceaux
nationalistes européens
un groupement pro nazi qui s'est
substituée aux femmes récemment dissous
par le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
giscard d'estaing a exprimé sa vive
indignation
dès que ces attentes ont été connus en
soulignant le caractère particulièrement
odieux des attaques contre les bâtiments
scolaires et tout à l'heure en fin
d'après-midi sur l'initiative des partis
de gauche et de nombreux syndicats une
manifestation de protestation s'est
déroulée devant le siège de la ligue des
droits de l'homme d'une rue jean moulin
a pas d'autres manifestations sont
prévues lundi et mardi à paris à l'appel
des différentes organisations mais
revoyant d'ange à l'instant avec
dominique dresse la chronologie des
friches des événements de la nuit passée
et des petites heures de la m tout a
commencé hier après-midi par ces
inscriptions racistes sur les murs d'une
école juive rue secrétan à paris une
école au passé tragique puisque tous les
élèves et enseignants ont été déportés
pendant la guerre
si le même établissement lucien de
hirsch qui a été visé ce matin une
dizaine d'impacts de balles ont été
relevés sur la façade de l'école
maternelle
deux heures auparavant c'était autour de
la crèche is rallye de la rue lamarque
est mitraillé
15 impacts de balles dans les vitrines
du dortoir des bébés dans cette flash
qui abrite 70 enfants c'est la
consternation
et maintenant la jeune fille qui ouvrait
la maison me téléphone le toit non le
plafond de la chambre des bébés
s'effondre très intelligent me dit ah
bon regardez avec un balai si c'est
grave je monte est géré au téléphone ça
minutes plus tard venait de demander aux
gardiennes passé le gardien monter dit
mais c'est pas le plafond il ya aussi
les vitres la jeune fille n'ayant pas vu
parce qu'ils aiment figue mi raisin à
7h20 du matin et on a vu des balles et
alors là c'est prévient la police
systématiquement l'un après l'autre tous
les symboles du judaïsme sont attaqués
4h45 la synagogue de l'association
consistoriale israélite de paris
des vitraux témoigne enfin des coups de
feu sont tirés à 5h15 con ce mémorial du
martyr juif
la façade est atteinte cet après midi
les responsables la communauté juive ont
tenu une conférence de presse pour
dénoncer ces attentats mais aussi et
surtout pour réclamer que justice soit
faite
je crois que certains hommes sur
l'importante revue jour où il annonce
une répétition chaîne de la violence
venant de la part des groupes néo-nazis
et dirigée contre eux des cibles qui est
sûre la communauté buts qui sont les
institutions démocratiques
ce n'est pas nouveau ça fait des années
que ça dure peut-être trois ans sinon
davantage
nous avons alerté à plus d'une reprise
des pouvoirs publics sur la gravité de
ces entreprises jusqu'ici à notre
connaissance aucune mesure concrète n'a
été prise
sauf un certain nombre de déclarations
de condamnation que nous sommes très
heureux d'entendre nous serions surtout
désireux aujourd'hui que les mesures qui
ont été prises récemment contre un autre
groupe terroriste écurité efficace le
soit prise aujourd'hui contre ces
groupes menti
notre présence au groupe action directe
qui a été injecté en fait quels pouvoirs
publics aussi les autorités ont réussi à
démanteler le groupement action directe
c'est parce que une enquête a été menée
d'une façon valable depuis le moment où
les attentats ont commencé et que dans
le domaine qui nous est proche il ne
semble pas que l'enquêté était poussé
jusqu'à son terme
il me semble que d'après les premières
réactions aussi bien du ministère
l'intérieur et de la préfecture de
police que de la mairie il semble que
cette phase iib enfin on va prendre les
choses au sérieux avant qu'il y ait mort
d'homme
alors le procureur de la république a
donné et fait exceptionnel des
instructions à la police judiciaire pour
que soit immédiatement entrepris
contrôle vérification et investigations
dans le cadre de l'enquêté ouverte à la
suite des attentats de ce matin les
réactions indignées ont été innombrables
elle est maire il faut lui dire de tous
les secteurs de la vie politique et
sociale
monsieur chirac maire de paris s'est
rendu dans l'école du 19ème
arrondissements touchés ce matin le
racisme at il dit est le mauvais des
maux de l'âme et il leur aval au niveau
de la bête il faut exorciser le parti
communiste et le parti socialiste sont
élevés chacun de son côté contre les
attentats le ps considère qu'il est
urgent d'organiser une réponse de tous
les démocrates
le pcf veut des mesures urgentes les
plus rigoureuses pour réprimer
l'activité des groupuscules fascistes
les fédérations naturellement des
associations d'anciens combattants et de
victimes de guerre ont été très forts
dans leur condamnation des événements de
la nuit dernière et ils les ont condamné
avec force et douleur ce qui s'est
produit est inadmissible et je voudrais
maintenant que jean françois kahn qu'au
delà des faits eux-mêmes que nous avons
rapporté qu'au delà des manifestations
qu'au delà des réactions ou me disiez
votre manière de france 3 qu'il d'abord
il faut pas réduire à l'activité des néo
nazis à une simple action à de simples
actions antisémites
ils s'en sont pris dans ces derniers
temps ils s'en sont pris à des militants
à de simples militants des droits de
l'homme qui n'était pas du tout juif
ils s'en sont pris à des résistants ils
s'en sont pris à des anciens combattants
ils s'en sont pris à des travailleurs
immigrés autrement dit leur cible il
faut bien le dire tel que cela est leur
cible
c'est tout simplement les cibles qui
était déjà celle
de leurs modèles adolf hitler ni plus ni
moins alors pourquoi font ils cela
je crois qu'il faut essayer de
comprendre ce que ce qu'ils cherchent
d'abord ce qu'il cherche nous disions
l'autre jour c'est de faire peur c'est
d'intimider et par la peur de paralyser
et ça aussi c'était une stratégie qu'ils
doivent à leur maître adolf hitler
mais les attentats d'hier à me sens
moins semble-t-il une autre but
ils veulent provoquer des réactions
inconsidérées
je m'explique ils se sont attaqués à une
école à une crèche aux monuments aux
moniales du soldat juif inconnu il est
bien évident imaginer cela que dans
certains milieux juifs il y a une
mission très forte des enfants des bébés
le symbole des victimes de la guerre il
ya une émotion très forte de la douleur
et même de la colère est alors la
tentation est grande bien sûr de dire
mais on peut pas laisser faire ça comme
ça on va pas se laisser faire comme une
autre fois il faut réagir et alors de
dire on va former des comités
d'autodéfense on va faire comme eux on
va aller là où ils sont on va comme a
dit certains leur faire leur fête
or c'est très dangereux c'est évidemment
très dangereux car d'une certaine
manière c'est ce qu'ils cherchent
l'un d'eux dans un interview à die très
nettement il a dit mais le désordre mais
nous sommes pour le désordre ça nous
réussit toujours regarder le chili et
l'argentine
seulement si on ne veut pas qu'il y ait
de réactions inconsidérées
il faudrait bien sûr qu'on ait
l'impression que les autorités prennent
conscience de ce nouveau danger et donne
l'impression de vouloir vraiment réagir
or c'est vrai qu'elles n'ont pas
toujours donné cette impression
c'est vrai que par exemple les groupes
gauchistes ont été démantelés action
directe c'est bien vient d'être
démantelé des autonome ont été arrêtés
des anarchistes aussi ont été
complètement dissous des groupes
anarchistes en revanche il n'y a pas eu
un seul pour l'instant auteurs
d'attentats néo fasciste ou néo nazis
qui ont été arrêtés c'est vrai aussi
semble-t-il que deux ou trois voire
quatre néo nazis se sont infiltrés dans
la police aujourd'hui il ya un problème
qu'on ne peut plus prendre à la légère
mais je michel debré est remis ce matin
sa démission de membres de l'assemblée
européenne l'ancien premier ministre
protestaient ainsi contre le fait que
certains élus de la liste dif
c'est à dire défense d
intérêts de la france en europe hésité à
appliquer la règle dite du tourniquet
avant les élections européennes les
candidats avaient pris l'engagement s'il
était élu de démissionner après un an de
mandat pour laisser leur siège à
d'autres signalons d'ailleurs que
monsieur michel debré président de la
liste au mythe cette liste était
dispensé de cette procédure
c'est dès l'année prochaine que les
familles nombreuses payeront moins
d'impôts je m'explique les familles de
trois enfants - devaient bénéficier
d'une demi part supplémentaire pour le
calcul de leur impôt
mais la mesure ne devait intervenir en
82 pour les revenus de 81
or un accord a été établi entre le
gouvernement et la majorité pour que
cette décision fut appliqué un an plus
tôt c'est à dire des 81 pour les revenus
de la présente année 1980 il en coûtera
un milliard de francs aux caisses de
l'état
le président de la république s'est
félicité de cet accord à l'occasion de
l'audience où il a reçu monsieur robert
revilla président de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale
la nouvelle carte universitaire proposé
par alice saunier c'est ministre des
universités soulève on le sait un
certain nombre de réactions qui sont
souvent défavorables certaines
universités en effet ont vu leurs
filières d'enseignement leur formation
sensiblement réduite
c'est le cas de l'université de picardie
une des plus touchées par la nouvelle
carte universitaire je vous invite à
suivre une enquête de dominique lo à
l'université de picardie la majorité des
étudiants n'est pas encore au travail
seul le service des inscriptions est
très anime un seul sujet de conversation
la nouvelle carte universités en fait
malgré la suppression de 11 habilitation
de troisième cycle et 4 du second toutes
les inscriptions sont acceptées
l'université se chargera ensuite en cas
d'impossibilité de formation des
transferts l'étudiant dans d'autres
établissements
mais tous ne pourront pas se déplacer
il est fort probable que nous ne
pourrons pas continuer nos études
voilà on dit c'est quelques c'est très
simple enfin pour moi c'est absolument
pas envisageable que je retourne à paris
pour suivre mes études
or pour mon métier j'estime que c'est
absolument nécessaire que j'ai une
formation un petit peu plus poussée et
plus sérieuse indiscutablement la
nouvelle carte ne ménage guère
l'université des formations de droit de
sociologie de psychologie de langues et
de philosophie sont supprimés des
mesures qui touchent près de 800
étudiants et par voie de conséquence des
professeurs on ne veut pas de la
philosophie des filets à flobecq les
gens et depuis socrate on sait très bien
sartre disait que c'est chez sophie qui
déterrent les pavés j'irai pas si loin
en fait dans la mesure où la philosophie
est une recherche pure désintéressé
fondamentale on les doit quand même pas
mal de choses
les disciplines scientifiques sont
également réduites
certaines correspondent à des formations
indispensables pour la région ainsi il a
fallu l'intervention d'une personnalité
politique de la majorité pour rétablir
le diplôme d études agroalimentaire une
filière vital pour la picarde
mais la biologie la pharmacie et les
diplômes de docteurs ingénieurs restent
supprime forte à craindre que le
renouvellement des équipes de recherche
puissent pas ce faire et qu'à terme les
équipements mes devoirs puisse
peut pas fonctionner faute de moyens
suffisants pour le ministre ces
suppressions sont légitimes amiens est
une université trop dispersé certaines
filières compte trop peu d'étudiants
quand il n'y a qu'une université dans
une région répond le président toute
suppression est une amputation pour la
province et ses habitants nous avons pu
constater que depuis quinze ans que
c'est développer l'enseignement
supérieur à amiens il ya une
transformation de la vie sociale de la
vie économique de l'activité d'une ville
comme amiens en fait ici on considère la
bataille universitaires comme la sphère
de toute la région
au-delà du débat politique qui existe en
toile de fond c'est l'ensemble des
personnalités régionales qui manifeste
sa préoccupation
max le jeune sénateur de la somme
raymond maillet président du conseil
régional ou encore le président du
comité économique et social de picardie
si au lieu d'avoir 9000 étudiants nous
n'en avons plus que 8000 ou 7000 par
tranche de 1000 étudiants ils environ
250 emplois de différentes natures
c'est donc autant d'emplois qui seront
supprimés
par ailleurs le flux d'étudiants
en tant dans l'activité locale est
extrêmement important à l'heure actuelle
et s'ils ne sont plus formés sur place
on peut craindre que les meilleurs
notamment ne trouvent de l'emploi autour
de l'endroit où ils auront su leur
formation et ne reviennent pas
revaloriser nos structures économiques
d'ensemble
nous reviendrons ces prochains jours sur
ces problèmes en vous présentant la
radiographie d'une autre université dans
les responsables au contraire s'estiment
satisfaits par la nouvelle politique
universitaire une dépêche que je viens
de recevoir pour découvrir le film
une perquisition était entreprise ce
soir par la police au siège des
faisceaux nationaliste européen fn dans
le 10e arrondissement qui avait
revendiqué les quatre temps antisémites
commis ce matin le siège défunt n se
situe dans le même immeuble que celui
qui abritait la fédération d'actions
masquant mal européenne c'est-à-dire la
femme mouvement d'extrême droite animée
par monsieur frédéric scène et dissous
le 3 septembre au vatican en la chapelle
sixtine synode mondiale sur la famille
ce matin plus de 200 évêques se sont
retrouvés avec les auditeurs et des
experts autour de jean paul ii pourra
mettre la même par laquelle s'ouvre est
cette cinquième assemblée générale
consacrée à la famille chrétienne et à
sa mission dans le monde contemporain
le pape dans son homélie invité les
participants à montrer à toutes les
familles qu'elles part elle avait dans
la mission de l'église et jean paul ii a
demandé ou pères du synode de réaffirmer
en ce domaine
l'enseignement du concile vatican ii
enfin le pape a insisté sur l'unité
entre les époux et sur le devoir de
protéger
l'amour et la fidélité le temps demain
et bien relever du jour il y aura des
brumes ou des brouillards en toutes
régions en cours de journée pluie
débutant près de la manche et gagnant
des régions au nord de la loire en
soirée ailleurs les éclaircies mais
prédominance de nuages ce soir vers 23
heures c'est pas la marque qui vous
donnera les dernières informations
demain antenne de midi et nous avons
rendez-vous si tel est votre choix
demain soir à 20 heures bonsoir merci